[Música]
es un gusto saludarlos Soy Paula Jiménez
Correa y les doy la bienvenida Así es
Asia el magacín quincenal de France 24
que aborda las múltiples realidades de
este continente Estos son nuestros
titulares
en Indonesia más de 270 fallecidos y
2.000 heridos es el saldo que deja un
terremoto de magnitud 5.6 grados que
sacudió el pasado 21 de noviembre la
provincia de Java la más poblada del
país entre los muertos hay al menos un
centenar de niños les contaremos porque
este sismo causó tanta devastación
se mantiene la atención en la Península
de Corea luego del reciente lanzamiento
de un misil intercontinental por parte
de Corea del Norte que sería capaz de
llegar a territorio estadounidense la
comunidad internacional ha condenado una
vez más estas acciones por parte del
régimen de
15tm ya esté listo para realizar su
primera prueba nuclear desde 2017
y Vamos hasta Tailandia que se convirtió
en el primer país asiático en legalizar
la marihuana Y aunque el gobierno quiere
promover el uso médico del Cannabis aún
no se ha aprobado en el parlamento una
ley que regule su uso recreativo lo que
deja un área gris legal que muchos se
apresuran a aprovechar
iniciamos nuestro recorrido por el
continente asiático en Indonesia
continúa la búsqueda de personas que
quedaron sepultadas bajo los escombros
por el terremoto de magnitud 5.6 del
pasado 21 de noviembre un grado que no
suele causar tantos estragos Aunque en
este caso el sismo tenía tres factores
especiales la zona en que se dio la
profundidad y la infraestructura de las
casas Alba Santana tiene los detalles
miles de personas aterrorizadas en
cientos de Vidas perdidas y miles de
casas destrozadas así dejó el terremoto
de magnitud 5,6 en la escala richter a
Indonesia con la provincia de Java
occidental la más densamente poblada del
país como la más afectada y ahora la
pregunta que muchos se repiten es sin
ser de tanta magnitud Por qué causó
tanta devastación este terremoto Aunque
el servicio geológico de Estados Unidos
indica que no hay una magnitud a partir
de la cual se produzcan daños Lo cierto
es que los terremotos de este tamaño no
suelen causarlos pero en el caso de
Indonesia una serie de factores se lo
hicieron especial la profundidad del
temblor de tan solo 10 kilómetros de
profundidad hizo que afectara más
directamente a la superficie y por tanto
a las casas de la gente casas que no
están construidas con diseños
antisísmicos que Podrían haber prevenido
tanta devastación algo que el presidente
del país ha prometido cambiará con la
reconstrucción de las viviendas
afectadas Y es que los indonesios tienen
que contar con que esta situación se
repetirá ya que el tercer factor que
contribuyó a la gravedad del fenómeno y
que destina el país a vivirlos es su
ubicación en mitad del conocido como
anillo del fuego una zona de choque de
placas tectónicas que abarca 400.000
kilómetros y donde se producen la
mayoría de terremotos del mundo en
Indonesia en febrero de este año un
terremoto mató a 25 personas otro en
enero de 2021 mató a 100 e hirió a más
de 6.500 siendo el del océano Índico de
2004 con el Tsunami que lo precedió el
más que acabó con la vida de 230.000
personas en una docena de países la
mayoría en Indonesia vamos ahora a Corea
del Norte que en los últimos días volvió
a hacer noticia en el mundo tras lanzar
un misil balístico intercontinental
capaz de alcanzar territorios
estadounidense Pues de acuerdo con el
Ministerio de defensa de Japón el
proyectil pudo tener un alcance de más
de 15.000 kilómetros se estima que lo
que va de este año el régimen de Kim
jong-un ha lanzado más de 30 proyectiles
elevando la alerta No solo en la región
sino también en la comunidad
internacional que ha condenado en
reiteradas ocasiones estas acciones que
preocupan ya que se teme que esté listo
para realizar su primera prueba nuclear
desde 2017 varios medios documentaron
que líder norcoreano apareció el día de
este lanzamiento con su hija por primera
vez en público otros medios hablan de
que la joven podría ser su segunda hija
a raíz de toda esta tensión a
continuación veamos algunos de los
misiles con los que cuenta Corea del
Norte
entre los más destacados se encuentran
los Jason el primero es el Jason 12 un
tipo de misil balístico de alcance
intermedio que pión llante a conocer en
2017 y que tendría un alcance máximo
estimado de 4.500 kilómetros el segundo
es el guasón 14 un misil con capacidad
de alcance de 8000 kilómetros el tercero
es el guasón 15 un misil que puede
alcanzar los 13.000 kilómetros lo que
pone en su punto de mira el territorio
continental de Estados Unidos y por
último se encuentra el corazón 17 el
misil más potente que tendría un alcance
de 15.000 kilómetros o más para hablar
de esto recientes y cada vez más
numerosos lanzamientos previamente
hablamos con Pío García profesor de la
facultad de finanzas gobierno y
relaciones internacionales de la
Universidad externado de Colombia que
nos explicó las implicaciones de estas
acciones consideradas por muchos países
de la región como peligrosas
son las implicaciones que son graves
porque pues pone aún más ingredientes a
una carrera armamentista en la región
creando zozobra en la región y da
ingredientes para una carrera
armamentista global pero no tiene la
urgencia y no es una situación tan de
emergencia como podría pensarse por el
hecho de que estos misiles que está
probando efectivamente son misiles de
largo alcance son misiles
sofisticados pero no tienen la letalidad
es decir no son misiles que porten
material nuclear bombas nucleares porque
para llegar allá la tecnología de Corea
del Norte todavía está rezagada es decir
que no son hasta ahora en sus misiles de
corto mediano y largo alcance de Corea
del Norte no tiene la capacidad para
proveer
con ojivas o sea con bombas
miniaturizadas que irían en la cabeza de
esos misiles en cuanto a Cómo reducir la
tensión en la región nuestro invitado
señala que una mesa de negociaciones
entre el régimen de varios actores
internacionales sería una salida en ese
sentido a mí me parece que lo que hace
falta es un papel más protagónico de el
consejo de seguridad de las Naciones
Unidas como parte de la negociaciones y
no solamente entre los países sino que
haya el departamento de energía atómica
la agencia internacional de energía
atómica el Consejo de Seguridad y el
secretario general de Naciones Unidas
con un papel más protagónico en una
reanudación de las conversaciones con
Corea del Norte frente a la situación de
su avance tecnológico en el campo
militar qué se puede esperar de Corea
del Norte en el futuro cercano eso nos
dijo nuestro invitado al respecto a
corto plazo Corea del Norte va a seguir
haciendo ensayos y enviando misiles que
son su llamado de atención a su
crítica a la situación militar en la
región su objetivo fundamental es
detener los ensayos anuales militares
que se hacen en Corea del Sur con
Estados Unidos entre las tropas de
Estados Unidos
de los cuales 30.000 efectivos están ahí
en el centro de Saúl permanentemente una
base militar muy grande y Desde esa base
militar se hacen ejercicios regulares
cada año nos dirigimos a Tailandia el
pasado mes de junio las autoridades
sorprendieron al mundo al eliminar el
cannabis de la lista de sustancias
consideradas estupefacientes al hacerlo
se convirtió en la primera nación
asiática en legalizar la marihuana
oficialmente el gobierno quiere promover
su uso médico pero aún no se ha aprobado
en el parlamento una ley que regule su
uso recreativo en sólo cuatro meses las
tiendas de cannabis han abierto en todo
el país y se espera que se convierta en
una industria mil millones de dólares en
los próximos cinco años
hace tan solo unos meses los tailandeses
se arriesgaban a pasar hasta 15 años de
prisión o incluso a la pena de muerte
por delitos relacionados con las drogas
pero desde junio el cannabis ha sido
despenalizado oficialmente el gobierno
dice que la planta debe usarse con fines
médicos no recreativos pero en la
práctica esa línea ya está borrosa
está convirtiendo rápidamente en el
ámsterdam de Asia en Países Bajos las
personas están limitadas a comprar 5
gramos por día pero en Tailandia no
existen estos límites el gobierno Espera
que su cambio de sentido ilumine una
industria de mil millones de dólares y
ayude al turismo a recuperarse después
de la pandemia de covid 19
fumar en público sigue siendo ilegal a
las personas que lo hagan se les puede
cobrar más de 680 dólares o tres meses
de prisión un gramo ahora cuesta poco
más de 15 dólares es más caro que antes
pero la calidad ha mejorado según los
empleados de esta tienda que dedican
tiempo a educar a los consumidores
entonces una prueba de buena calidad
tendría que ser tan Clara como esta Esto
es lo que espero algún día llegará a
Tailandia esto no podría ser más
significativo para mí que esto suceda y
finalmente pueda ejecutar mi propio
negocio de cannabis veces
acepto ese éxito
Esto es para ustedes amigos fumadores la
ley tailandesa actualmente restringe el
uso de cannabis a personas menores de 20
años pero las tiendas rara vez verifican
las identificaciones
la Industria Del Cannabis medicinal
también está en auge Ese es el enfoque
de esta granja ubicada a 250 kilómetros
a las afueras de Van Gogh
su nisa es una ex funcionaria de salud
convertida en empresaria es experta en
políticas de cannabis y thc el químico
psicoactivo que hace que los usuarios se
droguen
Tailandia se convertirá en un experto en
el uso del thc del Cannabis superaremos
a otros países como Estados Unidos y
Canadá será solo Tailandia el gobierno
ha prometido regalar un millón de
plántulas a los agricultores un intento
de revivir un cultivo utilizado en la
medicina tradicional durante siglos en
este hotel de lujo cerca del cultivo
sumisa ha abierto una clínica de
cannabis
pacientes de diversas enfermedades que
van desde el insomnio hasta el cáncer
terminal esperan beneficiarse de los
masajes y otros tratamientos con
extractos de marihuana en Tailandia no
existen regulaciones cuando se trata de
publicitar los beneficios del Cannabis
tampoco hay obligación de informar a los
clientes sobre los riesgos potenciales
asociados con su uso 1800 médicos han
solicitado que se revoque la
legalización
les preocupan los riesgos bien
documentados de la adicción y los
efectos negativos en los jóvenes
muchos incluso han hablado de una
alianza entre el Ministerio de salud que
está detrás de la política y la
Industria Del Cannabis bajo presión el
gobierno ahora está redactando
regulaciones adicionales sobre el
consumo de cannabis
y para el cierre les dejo este dato de
acuerdo con previsiones del fondo
monetario internacional India China y
Pakistán se encuentran entre los
primeros cinco países que registrarán un
mayor crecimiento a nivel del producto
interno bruto para el próximo año
llegamos al final de esta edición de Así
es Asia Muchas gracias por acompañarnos
y los invito a enviar sus comentarios a
las redes sociales que aparecen en sus
pantallas y a seguir toda la información
en nuestra página web France 24.com y no
olviden nuestra cita quincenal
[Música]